hi and welcome to my poster presentation
happy to meet you on the other side of
uh this screen uh if you have any
questions because of course
unfortunately we can't talk to each
other
please just send me an email there's an
email address on the bottom here
icha. if marshmallow is too complicated
just send me an email it's very german i
know uh just send me an email to info
tissues.com and i'll make sure that it
also reaches me okay let's just go
through the different figures together
at tissues we've developed 16 single
organ models on a chip
these include lung and kidney and
pancreatic eyelids
but also bone marrow testis and thyroid
models
also we have combined nine multi-organ
models these include
intestine liver liver pancreatic eyelids
liver skin
but also skin and lung tumor
or our four organ chip combinations
together we have more than 21 context of
use essays
on the right side you can see this is
our yuma mix starter
this can connect up to eight chips
and here you can see the tips so we have
the yamamic chip 2
which connects up to two organs we have
the you mimic tip 3 which can connect up
to 3
organs and we can also add a breathable
lip
for example for skin or lung models this
might be
interesting uh on then we have the
yamamic tip four and you can already
guess
this can connect up to four organs and
it also has a secretory circuit
and a second circuit for excretory media
for excretory products and then we have
the you mimic xx which can connect up to
10 organs
uh here just some examples of tissues
that have been integrated into our chip
system
we've developed our tip in a way for
plug and play for cell culture inserts
this means that we actually are able to
integrate for example commercial models
like
the epi intestinal model of matec or the
mucil air
from epitalx but also we can integrate
our own models
like here the skin model or biopsies
like here
on the other hand we can integrate for
example
ceramic scaffold as seen here in our
modern bone marrow model
um we can also integrate spheroids like
in
in the liver we usually combine at least
two different
cell types for the liver models for the
pancreatic eyelids
we actually use or work a lot with the
in sphero models which connect
alpha better and delta cells for our
thyroid model
we work with primary tissues where we
isolate the follicles
integrate them into a gel and then
integrate them into a chip
and of course we can cover all channels
with endothelial cells
what does an assay and tissues look like
we like i just mentioned we can work
with cell lines we can use with
primary cells ips derived cells but we
can also work with commercial models
biopsies or tissue slices
we add these into our chip then
start our culture of up to 28 days so
usually these are
7 to 28 days we can do safety or
efficacy testing
and repeated dose exposure regimen in
between we can do in process control so
for example we can do
daily blood surrogate analysis we can
look at metabolism
for example glucose or lactate we can
look at viability for example ldh and
others
and at the same time we can do
non-invasive process in process controls
like cell morphology molecular imaging
because of course
the tip is completely microscopable
we at the end of the culture we can
remove the tissue we can look at
histology
we can do qpcr analysis we can do
metabolite analysis
we can look at omics but we can also do
rna sequencing for example for
microarrays
we've also launched the umemic autolab
last year
so this is an automate which can
actually culture 24
chips so 48 replicates at the same time
it's a small automated research lab with
a high precision three actual
positioning system and
it is faulty uh fully automatic
operation and can
culture the chips for up to four days
this includes supply with nutrient
solution
solutions application of substances
optically topically or intravenously
and storage of samples substances and
media
this is in a safety cabinet is
has an automatic heating heating
integrated
and also a bright field and fluorescence
microscope
and we actually aim for high throughput
drug validation
and turbid regulatory acceptance with
our tips
um just to give you an example of how
important it is to
combine different organ models with each
other um
we here's an example where we combined
liver spheroids with pancreatic eyelids
and we cultured these for
15 days and if we look at the glucose
consumption
we can see that in single culture
either liver or eyelid we have a very
little
glucose consumption while if these two
tissues are in co
culture we actually see that after 24
hours we actually reach
a um a a area
which is physiological and if we capture
this for longer we can see that it
actually stays in this area
and um this is important to see that
there's actually difference and there's
a significant difference
for single culture compared to
co-culture
and the same thing we can actually see
for insulin production
if we have the eyelids alone they
produce and produce and produce insulin
whilst if they're in co-culture and in
crosstalk with the liver
they actually stop to produce insulin at
after eight approximately eight hours
and it stays about
constant after that time and you can see
that this
insulin production actually also is
significantly
reduced in co culture so this is just an
example to show you how
the cells actually interact with each
other how they cross
talk and how important it is to not only
have one culture
and maybe only a medium for um
going through the tissue but in a
circulatory system where the cells are
actually allowed to talk to each other
and with this i would like to end my
presentation i'm happy that you
stayed there until the end so again if
you have any questions just contact me
and
i hope next time uh it will be
face to face again and um i hope you
just enjoy the rest of the conference
and yeah hope to see you one day